le cinéma avec la sortie d'un bon film
de robert enrico son titre vent d'est
avec ludmila mikaël et pierre vaneck
entre autres le film raconte un épisode
méconnu de la seconde guerre mondiale
c'est l'histoire d'un général russe et
de ces hommes qui ont combattu les
soviétiques sur l'uniforme allemande
pour échapper à staline il se réfugie
dans un petit pays de 12000 habitants
parce qu'elle deschamps jean louis goût
serre dans la nuit du 2 au 3 mai 1945
une poignée de russes sous uniforme
allemand pénètre au liechtenstein pour y
chercher refuge
originaire d'ukraine ou des pays baltes
province annexée par staline
ils ont choisi de se battre dans la
wehrmacht contre l'armée rouge le
liechtenstein leur accorde le droit
d'asile et va refuser de livrer ses 500
hommes aux soviétiques
malgré leurs menaces malgré également
les pressions des alliés qui ont promis
à staline de lui livrer ces réfugiés
russes à yalta l'histoire est
authentique racontée par un britannique
lors de battles dans le dernier secret
une histoire que robert enrico a
découvert un peu par hasard
le secret a été bien gardé il ya deux
millions de citoyens soviétiques ont été
livrés à staline pour la plupart exécuté
mon rôle dans des camps je trouve ça
extraordinaire que les alliés n'en ai
pas parlé on en a qui a fait là son de
cloche là dessus et quand on voit tous
les documents carmen des textes saints
bouquin très épais ce sont des
témoignages des désordres officielle en
forme on voit tout tout tout tout le
là comment dire le la peur de staline de
la part des alliés
les crochets votre téléphone et demandé
aux américains ce qu'ils ont fait les
cosaques
hakan perse et aux anglais comment ils
ont organisé par la force des convois
entiers ap gets nous rendre mon traître
et quelques milliers d'habitants du
liechtenstein se retrouvent dans des
wagons à bestiaux qui en sort à quelque
chose pierre vaneck incarne ce premier
ministre du liechtenstein qui a tenu
tête aux soviétiques comme aux alliés je
pensais dernière phrase qui est celle
qui prolonge dans le film d'ailleurs qui
est une phrase napoléon jean garantit
pas l'authenticité mais ces délits et
admiral de voir qu'à la fin l'esprit et
finit toujours par triompher du sabre et
c'est un peu ce que fait cet homme
pendant pendant tout ce temps pendant
tout le film par un toast sp2 de combat
contre le monde entier d'une certaine
façon sur les 500 hommes du général
smith love qui 200 finalement été
convaincue par la commission soviétique
de rentrer chez eux ils ont été exécutés
dès leur arrivée sans procès à voir en
ce moment donc sur les écrans